I got asked out on the job twice and it
was just a little bit awkward just say
yeah what if I got extra - never have I
ever eaten the customers leftovers for
sure
Oh a hundred percent I have know
everyone I wanted to pretend to like
push it in the in the garbage and just
sneak a couple pop worship I've even hit
a couple smite swine before once or
twice come bring it to the dish area you
know say look around for a little bit do
a quick run you know sanding you back on
the floor makes the job easier but then
you got a look at the customers - and be
like would I like make out with them and
that's a good judgment of well I would
eat that food is there I mean never have
I ever dropped food but still served it
[Music]
I mean I've got that couple of
pepperonis before the pizza restaurant I
worked out on the floor before it was
cooked and then just picked the back up
do it on the thing and right back in the
oven the bench next to the plate I don't
know that cow probably fun dropping on
the floor it wasn't like a big deal you
know what I mean it wasn't like on a
very dirty ground or anything definitely
dropped food before and thought about
serving it but I just seized the
opportunity to eat it myself oh they
were so mean the customers were so mean
and it dropped on the floor for like
three seconds and I picked it up and
looked at my coworker and he was like I
didn't see anything okay never have I
ever spat in a customer's food
[Music]
in movies and it's too much nothing it's
guys definitely if not again but like
really wanted to when I just so rude oh
my god you have they deserved it this
lady she ordered very specifically and I
got her order 100% right she wanted to
complain about it because she wanted her
meal for free I said ma'am I wrote
everything down
word for word she called me a derogatory
name about my race and threw her ice at
me so when she got her correct food this
time it was a little bit extra correct
that's relevant if they call you a name
I get that they came at me they threw
the drink at me so hard what did you
expect never have I ever lied about
knowing if a dish had gluten or some
other product in it or not I was still
in training and she asked if the soup
was vegan and there's tomato soup so I
took a chance and was like yes whatever
it's not the stock in the soup is
actually chicken stock and it's tomato
bisque which is like 90 percent cream
learn my lesson from that anything
better I feel like most people don't
even know what gluten is so when they
say to me I'm like I don't know and they
asked me if it has good it's like shitty
you know like if a potato has gluten in
it I don't know I have when I was more
ignorant about those things because I
started working in the restaurant
business so I was like 16 so I remember
the first time I got asked that question
and I was like oh no there's not but
then I had a friend whose mom had celiac
disease and I very quickly learned the
like seriousness of it and I was like
okay lesson learned I will always
triple-check ingredients never have I
ever given bad service because I thought
they wouldn't tip well I've never even
bachelor's because I didn't think
anybody was gonna be a bad tipper but I
mean there's obviously been times where
you know your soul is just not into it
as you know you know
I may have but I also haven't because
this happens to me because I'm foreign
yeah I've noticed that service will be
really rude to me from the start
some timings yeah they're like she's
fine she's not gonna tempt I'm like whoa
actually I'm literally gonna tip better
than everyone else yeah and I'm always
right yes I'm always right never have I
ever messed up an order on purpose what
would the purpose yeah that's what I'm
thinking I'm like what would the purpose
of that be that's just gonna give this
guy cause hell yeah I don't think I have
no definitely a lot by mistake oh I've
never messed it up on purpose I think
the mistakes come from just kind of
zoning out and not being focused enough
I have definitely Mets up an order on
purpose cuz I thought the person was
like a meat ass I thought that was just
funny like someone had like a lot of
allergies supposedly you know like they
were gluten free and were flour free I
mean worked at a pizza restaurant they
ended up just go for doing the order
wrong and if can't bring it back it made
me laugh never have I ever dated a
customer huh yeah think about that one
we'll go with the safe answer here I
have none I wish I would've I have not
I've had a lot of have you yeah I've
worked in boss okay say I've never
worked in a bar so those never it was
always just breakfast food yeah so the
type of people that were asking me out
were like 50 year olds and that yeah
I've definitely gone out to drink with
cute guys up man hell yeah
never have I ever had sex at work hey
that'd be rather tough
I haven't but I know people that have I
never thought I would admit that it was
with an old co-worker there was no one
around if that is makes up for it in the
freezer kind of disappointing first I
feel like I know I wish I could flip it
around I really do all right it's an
interesting industry to be in sucks
sometimes sometimes it's wonderful I
don't to be cliche but you know
sometimes like to see the smile on
people's faces they're happy people when
you're working in this industry
sometimes sometimes there are definitely
really interesting stories that can come
from customers who are just a little bit
off or super rude to you you should
always be nice to your servers like
they're taking care of your food they're
working so hard have power they're also
taking care of six other tables at the
same time times smaller regardless of
how much I hated working and still do
hate working in the restaurant industry
it's actually kind of fun and there's a
lot of good stories you can tell I feel
like we have the same general yeah.but
answers to the questions so no matter
what kind of restaurant you work out I
feel like it's all kind of the same
[Music]
[Music]